البحر الاحمر يشتعل شراسه ولهيبا وتوترا
القصف باكثر من 200 طائره مسيره واكثر من
50 صاروخا بالستيا ومجن احا استهداف سفينه
حربيه امريكيه
وابعاد جماعه الحوثي ل سفينتين تجاريتين
امريكيتين حكومه صنعاء تشتبك مع المدمرات
الامريكيه في خليج عدن من جديد واشنطن
تلجا للصين لكبح جماح الجيش اليمني وتل
ابيب تكشف عن ورقه ضغط تجعل السعوديه
تقترب من التطبيع السيسي يرفض الرد على
النتنياهو ويقول حروح من ربنا فين لو انا
السبب القتال بين تلبيب ولبنان يقترب من
التحول لصراع شامل وسكان المنطقه يلوذون
بالفرار الفصائل تبدي استعدادها لترك
الاسرى من النساء والاطفال فما المقابل
امريكا تتجه لسحب قوتها من العراق وسلاح
روسي جديد يدخل ارض المعارك الاوكرانيه
ومجلس الامن الدولي يعقد قمه طارئه بشان
اسقاط طائره روسيه بينما الدفاع الروسيه
تعلن تدمير منظومه صواريخ فرنسيه للمره
الاولى خليج عدن
يشتعل ابو اليمن يواصل ضرب السفن
الامريكيه والبريطانيه في خليج عدن حتى
اشعار اخر حيث كانت هيئه عمليات التجاره
البحريه البريطانيه اعلنت انها تلقت بلاغا
عن انفجار وقع قرب سفينه في مضيق باب
المندب على بعد 50 ميلا بحريا من مناء
المخا فيما كانت القياده الوسطى الامريكيه
قالت ان الجيش اليمني اطلق ثلاث صواريخ
بالستيه على صفينه ديترويت الامريكيه
بخليج عدن مضيفه ان صاروخا واحدا سقط في
البحر وتم الاشتباك مع الصاروخين الاخرين
بنجاح واسقاطه بواسطه السفينه العسكريه
جرايف لي وكانت حكومه صنعاء اعلنت عن
اشتباكها مع عدد من من المدمرات والسفن
الحربيه الامريكيه في خليج عدن وباب
المندب وبحسب الناطق العسكري في صنعاء
يحيى سريع فقد كانت من نتائج عمليه
الاشتباك اصابه سفينه حربيه امريكيه اصابه
مباشره رغم محاوله السفن الحربيه اعتراضها
واجبار السفينتين التجاريتين الامريكيتين
على التراجع والعوده وفق تعبيره هناك نقلت
صحيفه فاينانشال تايمز عن مسؤولين
امريكيين ان الولايات المتحده طلبت من
الصين حث طهران على كبح جماح صار الله
الحوثيين الذين يهاجمون السفن التجاريه في
البحر الاحمر لكنها لم تتلقى اي مؤشر يذكر
على المساعده من بيكين وذكر التقرير ان
الولايات المتحده اثارت الامر مرارا مع
مسؤولين الصينيين كبار في الاشهر الثلاثه
الماضيه واليكم المصدر نقل صحيفه
فاينانشال تايمز اليوم عن مسؤولين
امريكيين قولهم ان الولايات المتحده طلبت
من الصين حث طهران على كبح جماح الحوثيين
لوقف هجماتهم في في البحر الاحمر دوليا
قال مفوض السياسه الخارجيه للاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيب بوريل ان تلبيب لا تتمتع
بحق الفيتو ضد قيام دوله فلسطين وكان وزير
الخارجيه الايطالي انطونيو تاجاني قال في
حديث لقناه سكاي نيوز الرابعه ان سياسه حل
الدولتين لا تزال قابله للتطبيق حتى بعد
تصريحات رئيس الوزراء العبر نتنياهو بينما
افادت القناه الث3 العبريه بان مكتب
النتنياهو حاول مؤخرا تنسيق اتصال له مع
الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي ولكن تم
رفضه من قبل الرئاسه المصريه وكان الرئيس
المصري قد قال حاروح من ربنا فين لو انا
السبب لينفي بذلك اغلاق معبر رفح من جهه
مصر مشيرا الى ان الاجراءات التي يتبعها
الجانب العبري هي ما يعطل دخول المساعدات
الى القطاع وهنا ذكرت صحيفه وال ستريت
جورنال نقلا عن مسؤولين مصريين ان الفصائل
ابدت استعدادها للتوصل الى اتفاق مع تلبيب
حول اطلاق سراح النساء والاطفال لل
العبريين المتبقين لديها ولنتصور
هذا وحذر موقع هاكول هاودي اي الصوت
اليهودي من ان التخلي عن احتلال رفح قد
يكون اعترافا رسميا من جانب تلبيب بخساره
الحرب والحفاظ على حكم الفصائل في القطاع
انسانيا علق وزير الماليه العبري بيتسا
ايل سموتريتش على الانباء حول صفقه لتبادل
الاسراء الفص تشمل هدنه لمده شهرين بالقول
ان وقف الحرب في القطاع لمده طويله خطوه
خطيره بحسب موقع ايان هناك عبرت صحيفه
جوزليم بوست عن مخاوف من ان تؤدي حرب
طويله الامد ربما طوال العام الجاري الى
سلسله من التكاليف المؤلمه بما في ذلك
مقتل الرهائن ومئات الجنود وتوجيه ضربه
قاضيه للاقتصاد على ذات السياق افاد
سموتريتش لعائله المحتجزين العبريين في
القطاع انه لا يمكن التعهد باعاده جميع
المحتجزين الاحياء وذلك وفق تسجيل صوتي
مسرب نشرته صحيفه اسرائيل اليوم من جانبه
صرح الوزير في مجلس الحرب العبري في كلمه
متلفزه نشرتها هيئه البث الرسميه كان بان
حكومه الطوارئ في بلاده ستتخذ قرارات صعبه
لاعاده المحتجزين لدى الفصائل بالقطاع ان
كانت هناك صفقه حقيقيه وفي قضيه التطبيع
اكد وزير الطاقه العبري الي كوهان امكانيه
التطبيع مع السعوديه حتى لو رفض التلبيب
التحرك نحو قيام دوله فلسطينيه وقال كوهان
في مقابله مع صحيفه تايمز اوف اسرائيل ان
المخاوف الامنيه المتعلقه بالمحور
الايراني ستتفوق على مطالب الرياض بان
يكون حل الدولتين جزءا من صفقه التطبيع
مشددا على ان السلامه مع السعوديه امر
وارد تماما وفي قطر اعربت وزاره الخارجيه
عن استنكارها الشديد لتصريحات رئيس
الوزراء العبري في تقارير اعلاميه مختلفه
حول الوسطه القطريه وكانت القناه الثان
العبريه نقلت عن النتنياهو قوله ان قيام
قطر بدور الوسطه في صفقه التبادل مع
القطاع يمثل اشكاليه اكثر من الامم
المتحده والصليب الاحمر على الحدود
اللبنانيه يقترب القتال بين تلبيب ومقاومه
لبنان من التحول الى صراع شامل ما دفع
السكان على جانبي الحدود الى الفرار بحسب
صحيفه و ستريت جورنال فيما حاضت الحكومه
الفرنسيه اللبنانيين على عدم الانخراط في
حرب مع تلبيب خلال ذلك يعمل دبلوماسيون
امريكيون على الوساطه من اجل التوصل الى
اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار بين الجانبين
وقالت الصحيفه ان القتال اشتد هذا الشهر
على الرغم من ان لبنان لم يستخدم اسلحه
طويله المدى بعد وعدم اصدار تل ابيب اوامر
بتحريك دباباتها ولا احد يعرف الى متى
يمكن ان تستمر المعركه الحدوديه قبل ان
تتحول الى حرب عنيفه وها هو المصدر يتحدث
ابلغ وزير الدفاع الفرنسي القياده
الاسرائيليه بان باريس تجري مناقشه خطوات
عمليه بشكل معلن وغير معلن بهدف منع نشوب
حرب بين اسرائيل وحزب الله لننتقل الى
العراق حيث ذكرت وكاله رويترز نقلا عن
اربعه مصادر ان الولايات المتحده وبغداد
بصدد بدء محادثات تهدف الى انهاء مهمه
التحالف العسكري الذي تقوده الولايات
المتحده في العراق وكيفيه استبداله
بالعلاقات الثنائيه وهي خطوه في عمليه
توقفت بسبب الحرب في
القطاع ضربه
قاسيه بعد ان تلقى جنود الاوكران ضربه غير
متوقعه في طريق عودته من الاسر البوصله
الروسيه تشير نحو كياف وكانت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه قالت ان القوات الاوكرانيه
استهدفت طائره النقل الروسيه التي كانت
تحمل الاسرى الاوكرانيين بنظام صاروخي
مضاد للطائرات في منطقه ليبسي بمقاطعه
خاركوف شرق اوكرانيا وكان على متن الطائره
سته من افراد الطاقم و65 اسيرا اوكرانيا
للتبادل وثلاثه عسكريين روس يرافقونه لقوا
حذفهم جميعهم هناك استجاب مجلس الامن
الدولي لدعوه موسكو الى عقد جلسه طارئه
بشان اسقاط الطائره وهنا نتصفح المصدر
وذكرت صحيفه استرانا الاوكرانيه نقلا عن
مصادرها ان الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه كانت
على علم بتبادل الاسر قبل اسقاط قوات كياف
طائره النقل العسكريه التي كانت تحمل 65
اسيرا اوكرانيا من جانب اخر دع وزير
الدفاع البريطاني جراند تابس ان الولايات
المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي للاقتداء بلندن
وزياده الدهم العسكري لاوكرانيا وذلك على
صفحته على موقع التواصل الاجتماعي اكس
ليصرح وزير المال الالماني كريستيان ليدن
ان المانيا لن تكون قادره على مساعده
اوكرانيا بمفردها وحذر ليدن من عبء مالي
محتمل اذا اضطرت المانيا الى تحمل العبء
المالي للصراع في اوكرانيا وحدها ودعا
اعضاء الاتحاد الاوروبي الاخرين الى زياده
دعمهم لكيف كما اعترف نائب رئيس برلمان
سلوفاكيا لو بوش بلاغا ان مواطني بلاده
سئموا حقيقه ان بلاده تقدم مساعدات هائله
لاوكرانيا لا تؤدي الا الى الفقر والموت
في روسيا افادت صحيفه روسي سكيا جازيتا ان
موسكو انتهت من اختبار صواريخ مضاده
للدروع سيتم تسليمها قريبا للجيش الروسي
في منطقه العمليه العسكريه الخاصه وقالت
القناه 360 الروسيه ان صواريخ المصغره
ستستخدم من قبل نماذج مطوره لمنظومه بانت
ستير اس ام المضاده للجو التي تعمل في
منطقه العمليه العسكريه الخاصه منذ عام
2003 بالمقابل وبعد تجنيد الاف الاجانب
للقتال في صفوف جيشه ضد روسيا الرئيس
الاوكراني زيلينسكي اقترح منحى الجنسيه
الاوكرانيه للمقاتلين الاجانب دون ان
يضطروا الى التخلي عن جنسيتهم الاصليه
وتجنيس المقاتلين المنحدرين من اصل
اوكراني واحفادهم ما عدا مواطني الدوله
المعتديه على السياده الاوكرانيه هناك
افادت صحيفه اي بي سي الاسبانيه بان
اخفاقات اوكرانيا في الصراع مع روسيا ومنع
المساعدات الغربيه تسببت في اصابه الرئيس
زيلينسكي بالياس ليجد نفسه في وضع صعب
للغايه واضافت الصحيفه ان زيلينسكي يفشل
في الصراع مع روسيا وحلفاء متعبون ميدانيا
اعلنت القوات الروسيه تدمير مستودعات
ذخيره لوائين من القوات الاوكرانيه وللمره
الاولى تدمير نظام صاروخي من طراز سامب تي
مضاد للطائرات فرنسي الصنع من جانبها
اعلنت البعثه الروسيه لدى المنظمات
الدوليه في فينا ان الدفاعات الروسيه
اسقطت 133 مسيره اطلقتها قوات كياف من
محطه زبروجيا النوويه ومدينه انجود دار
المحاذيه خلال اسبوع
[موسيقى]
f